j'ai l'impression pardonnez-moi mais
j'ai l'impression que vous brûlez
d'envie de faire un petit peu
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous dire
la vérité franchement
c'est comme je vous dire j'ai fait des
arts martiaux j'ai pas le droit de me
battre en dehors du tatami
tout ça j'ai pas le droit de danser
voilà face à un collègue voilà quand on
est du même niveau on n'a pas envie tu
vois
non plus ça va vous sinon vous voulez
[Rires]
combien de temps il vous faut pour lui
mettre des talons et qui dansent comme
vous comme la chorégraphie
trois mois non 3 mois
et vous avez déjà vu danser c'est pour
ça que j'ai 3 mois
mais danser dans son talon c'est
différent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un peu magnifique voilà il y a même de
la sensualité contre
toi
c'est incroyable si vous avez des
questions je suis en train de refaire
je veux bien manger je te fais un petit
défilé ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais je suis bien je suis bien content
de au final les choses se font bien
parce que je
m'a proposé dams la première année on
parlait pas du retour de la Star Ac
d'accord donc j'étais intéressé ceci dit
quand j'ai fait les screens j'avais fait
les deux en même temps Sarah et dals et
je voulais vraiment faire comme le mec
qui rit il a fait Daniel et Delphine
c'est fou ça tu vois
on était très content de te voir ce soir
merci à vous dire le téléspectateurs qui
te regardent qui t'aime la France ben
non juste merci merci pour tout le
soutien que je que je reçois depuis
depuis la Star Ac depuis mais même en
gêne et en général
quand tu es content dans la vie je suis
content ouais je suis content il y a des
hauts et des bas comme tout le monde
mais bien sûr mais ça va
je suis heureuse d'être là ce soir en
tout cas c'est vrai bah nous aussi on
était content de te voir applaudissement
[Applaudissements]